cake ladder cake bladder cake ladder
cake ladder cake bladder cake bladder
cake
[Music]
good morning
gamers I'm back and boy oh boy does it
feel good to be back
what up you're again what's up my man
what up Sven what up what up Sven jr.
today we have some very important things
to do
first things first I've been meaning to
do this for a long time
chop dead no more beetroot Oh see that
beetroot murdered you're gone today's
episode will be focused on IKEA Tower we
have the new glorious IKEA Tower with
one fatal flaw there's no way for Jurgen
to get up there it's just impossible not
fair we need to build a horse ladder
which is also known as cake ladder
that's right cake ladder you heard me
right we need to somehow get rid of the
old tower but it needs to be respectful
okay it needs to be done in a respectful
manner we will do both of these things
the ingredient for cake to make a cake
it's of course sugar milk and egg so we
need to build a farm for both these
things it shouldn't be too hard I
already have a milk farm aka cow too but
I want to build I want to build that
little cute little chicken house so
we're gonna do that
where should we build it here okay let's
build a hair spin good old-fashioned
building with my boy just watch out for
that creeper spin why do I hear chickens
now
I lost it finally how big do I want it
except chickens underneath the ground
hello it's fake
I forgot my fake it alright help be
patient one oh my god that's so funny
if you think I look like you know more
trashy than usual just know it's because
I've been playing Minecraft I get
somebody comment sometimes being like Oh
Felix looks so nasty if it look it looks
so tired
yeah minecraft its redstone I'll be
snorting redstone all right we got our
floor done yeah that's cool and I really
missed this just me and my boy building
some epicness in Minecraft like that's
cool
but I mean the idea is pretty simple
just put a bunch of hoppers into one
chance I just realized that harder I
make it for them to move the better the
farm so that's awesome alright pretty
cute
alright so then let's go get
oh my god its fakie ah Jesus what's that
fakie you're really excited to finally
be freaking awesome cool follow me I
know you'd have a purpose you know
people kept saying you were a useless
character I mean low-key kind of cozy
what's that
you missed your chair you want to be
lord of the chickens okay all right fine
it's not fine stop crying I'll get you
your chair just wait here
Jesus Christ you know what good enough
close enough the chicken monarch
everyone has been conceived now we just
need to find more chickens very well
there is one don't ask me what happened
there
follow me sweet child
what's your name Mathilde Mathilde you
will you will live here and you will
conceive babies with fading ok have fun
you two
all right so next on the list is we need
sugar which comes from the sugar cane
farms that should be pretty easy to make
I feel like we can just make a Serie
tech farm how do you like this aimer
having a good time in there that's what
I thought that's what off hey get down
from there children or women no one
escape ok so each chicken will go in
each card am i afraid
absolutely I mean it should it should
work maybe not the most humane but it's
still like I'm not looking to win human
Tyrion of the Year awards I'm trying to
change the Minecraft game isn't that
right side all right so just like if you
have any problems just take it up with
your supervisor all right cool
I'll leave you to it I got a builder
zero take sugar farm oh Jesus that's
loud
she says hello okay
three hours later
all right organ I think yeah hey all
right
Oh God let's see how it's go whoa so
much egg so much eggs man yeah
damn what if I make many of these I
could be rich
faster faster
all right so we're really missing wheat
we already have a wheat farm soon you're
again soon you will be able to rise to
the stars
oh yeah the Nexus titty no wrong way
move more like a move damn that's some
fast milking damn it this seemed like a
good idea it's a piece of cake to make a
pretty cake god damn this thing is a
piece you guys could definitely improve
however all right let's make our first
cake I of course know how to make cake
in brain one two okay good I don't need
that many eggs that's perfect hey cake I
made a cake so the idea is to build a
cake liner up to the IKEA Tower no I'm
not the madman no I'm not the fool I'm a
man with a dream I'm a visionary so the
idea of the ladder cake is that you can
walk up each step because you can eat
the cake in six steps
so we're gonna build a cake lighter it's
a cake lighter my god one one day I'm
gonna go there to this there's just
gonna be a black hole at least yeah this
is pretty good all right we're gonna
make a lot of cakes one two three cake
shadow cake shadow oh my god
my dumb ass built it on the wrong axis
but still it's beautiful
I built this fence thing nine out of
five dentists approve it
damn I love meatball is so pretty today
let's test it out with your again a
uragan smear again got the surprise for
you it was getting dark we can look at
the sky together let's took a lot of
effort so you better freaking like it
cake ladder take lighter cake lighter
cake lighter cake lighter cake bladder
cake oh god how do I get down oh god how
do I get that I'm freaking safe lighter
say clatter uh I want to go again that
was awesome
Bengt what are you doing oh it's so fast
and now finally Jurgen can enjoy
whoo yeah cake ladder cake ladder it's
so good it's so fast okay at demo so
proud of everything is so beautiful look
at that before we made jargon I got far
wicked are you going look at all this
sub turtles the new IKEA Tower is
glorious but the old IKEA power it's
time to move on I need to figure out
what to do with you
[Music]
I think there's only one thing to do is
to send her off send her off to space to
go and beyond where no IKEA Power has
gone before
all right I got a lot of work to do to
complete this dream
[Music]
like yet our I'll always remember you
you were there since the beginning
you've been there all this time friend
why does IKEA tower have to go okay but
I can't look
spend jr. don't look don't look
I loved you more than a friend I loved
you like a father like a lover but it's
time for you to return home IKEA tower
it's time to for you to return to the
stars I know it's the right thing to do
even though I not ready to let go you're
again hit the switch
[Music]
there she goes back to the stars
we're only to review the connexxus
sayonara I care son
I promise no buy a Kia tower I'll miss
you
promise me to call promise you'll call
[Music]
thank you guys for watching this episode
smash like if you enjoyed subscribe
check out the merch and most of all bye
bye IKEA though to infinity and beyond
[Music]
you
Jeff laughs ah you haven't played
PewDiePie pixel in yet you clearly don't
understand the game is so great
hold on two chairs it might even make
tuber simulator irrelevant check it out
you